hey today's show we're going to be
talking about parent transitions
and how do you reconnect with your
partner after you drop that last kid off
at school
we're going to be talking about how to
support your wife or your husband
when your in-laws just aren't coming
through we're going to have an awesome
segment talking about grandparents
how to support and love your
grandparents as they get older
and how grandparents can love and
support and even surprise their
grandkids stay tuned
what is up good folks i'm john and this
is the dr john delony show
a show for you about you and by you
where we take your live calls we talk to
real people with real challenges about
relationships relational iq
mental health adhd depression anxiety
relationships
being a good girlfriend or boyfriend
sometimes we talk about people who say
the words
um i'm a cat mom or um
yeah i don't have kids but i'm a cat
mom what like there's a couple of people
at work talking about their kids and
then they're like oh
yeah exactly i'm a dead a dog dad
and it's so the same thing here's here's
the spoiler alert everybody
it's super not super not cat moms
not a real thing that's not a thing it
it's super not a real thing
dog parents nope you have a pet that you
can put in a cage
in the side of your house that's just a
thing so here's the deal
we can talk about that all that's a
whole other thing if you're looking for
honesty in a world where truth doesn't
exist anymore
if you want a first opinion a second
opinion if you just disagree with your
neighbor and you want a mediator
give me a call i'm here to walk with you
my number is 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-6933
again keep the emails coming at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
leave your name your number leave a a
synopsis of what's going on in your
heart and your mind and your
relationships and we will get back in
touch with you
and god help you dude if you're a cat
mom probably this isn't
this isn't the show for you all right
hey let's go straight to the phones
let's go let's go to cindy in austin
texas first
cindy good morning how we doing the 512.
doing awesome thank you so how can i
help this morning
so um i have been a stay-at-home mom for
a long time and um
i my hope my kids are my entire life for
the last 25 years
i dreamt of being a mom since i was a
little girl
once i had them i poured everything i
had into them i'm very proud of who they
are today
our last child will be graduating
college this year and so
as to be expected my husband and i will
be empty nesters soon
and i honestly looking back and looking
forward i've done a disservice to him
because i've always put him second to
the kids
just because i wanted to do the best i
could with them and now
i i want to make it up now during the
empty nest few years and i was kind to
see if you gave me advice on how to do
this best and how we can reconnect
what a beautiful question so real quick
how old are you sound like you're about
19 i'm 49 thank you
[Laughter]
it's not even how you look anymore it's
like oh i sound young i'll take that
that's cool
oh cindy that's fantastic okay so 49 how
long have you and your husband been
married
oh for 30 years 30 years okay so give
give me the state of the union of your
marriage
how are things are they good does he
love you is
he seeing somebody else on the side are
you like
give me the state of the union we're
really good like we're we're
we've done a really good job of
balancing out you know parenting and
stuff but you know for the first
in our 20s and 30s and 40s we were just
grinding trying to
do the best we could raise our family
you know hit him work and stuff like
that
so when you say you put him when you say
you put him second what does that mean
just like uh always the girls always
worried about
um what they were doing if they were
doing good making sure i spent time with
them making sure i was invested in what
they were involved in
getting up with them at night to talk
and um um
they were talkers and you know late at
night that's when we do things you know
we don't
we don't let them keep their cell phones
in the room so i made sure i was up
until they went to bed i could get their
cell phones from them
and you know he's just doing the dad
thing and working really hard and so i
was
always putting the girls first making
sure that they were good because i
wanted to make sure that when they left
the house
i could say i did my best with them so
that's honorable and i want to high-five
you there all the way from nashville
what are ways that you show your husband
that you desire him
that he is loved that you think he's a
person of value
so i've come to realize that you know
those personality traits like
how you look for love and affection i'm
very much a service oriented person
okay and i show love to him and other
people by doing things for them and i
hope that they interpret that as my love
for them so i figured out that's what i
do for him i mean he always has
you know warm meals and just clothes
washed and the clean
house and you know awesome i think i
feel like that
and um and he's very he's very much a um
awards he likes sports
and that hasn't been my forte whole
marriage and i'm trying to change that
now
um he's a good good guy i mean he's
amazing and awesome i just i've honestly
put him second
for the last 25 years well number one i
want to applaud you for recognizing that
i want to applaud you for being
a mom who kept the house together for 25
years and he really
doubled down and dedicated her life to
her daughters to her husband to
just being the ceo of your house and
that's that's a noble calling and
i also want to honor the fact that
you're recognizing that you're
changing stations here in life and that
you want to
make changes yourself and you want to
reconnect with your husband that's a big
big deal
and that puts you ahead of so many other
people i've worked with
i can't even tell you how many families
who are dropping kids off at college
over the years
and then they just get home i mean
they're driving home and they look at
each other and it's like who are you
and that reverberates through their kids
it reverberates through the parents
so high five to you so here's a couple
of things
i want you to think through and i wish i
had a better analogy than what i'm going
to give you
it's just the one pops in my head here
and so
for the vegans in the audience or the
pita folks this isn't going to be a
great example but it's the best one i
got
so anytime there is a transition in a
marriage
right from a new kid the
aftermath of an affair moving to a new
town
after a cancer diagnosis after the loss
of a parent or empty nesting
any sort of transition there's a
temptation and for good reason right
there's a temptation to try to reclaim
the past to try to
go back and get what was right remember
when we were young
and we just made out all the time and i
look super good and you look [ __ ] like
right there's this this temptation to to
go back and get what was and bring it
into
our new place or our new season and what
was
was beautiful they're great memories
beautiful love and joy
peace wild fun great sex all that stuff
right
but when you try to drag the past into
the present it often arrives
dead or not quite as awesome as we
remember it and it's covered in leaves
and sticks and
and again i apologize the only analogy i
can think of
is deer hunting when you just shoot a
deer in the woods and you've got to drag
it all the way to
where your car is or to where the
polaris is
it just isn't this majestic beautiful
thing that you saw on the mountaintop
right it's a dead animal
and so esther perel she's a relationship
expert she's somebody that um
is is really elevated in the
relationship
space she's a brilliant brilliant
thinker and writer
she talks about this beautiful notion
and tell me how this fits in your soul
cindy how this how this resonates with
you
she says adults will often have three or
four deep
loves in their lifetime in their adult
life
and the lucky ones or the ones who work
really hard
experience those loves with the same
person
and so you've got this smoking hot
husband of yours right this lovely
lovely husband
and you met him and that was love number
one then you got to be in love and
experience life for 25 years with this
hard-working provider who also loved you
deeply but love looked differently
and now you're at relationship number
three with the same guy
right how does that sound does that
sound right
that sounds right yeah okay so here's
what i want you to
reconsider i want you to reconsider not
recreating the past
not trying to get back once what was but
i want you to
try to build something new and building
something new
means you get the excitement of being an
architect you get the excitement of
being an engineer
you don't have to be an archaeologist
you don't have to go back and try to
drag something that was
you get to paint an entirely new picture
and so to do this you got to be honest
with
who each other is right now who you've
become
and where you guys want to go which is
so rad
so when's the last time you guys went
out on what i would call and again this
is going to be different for everybody
on a smoking hot date when's the last
time y'all went out
like smoking hot like just me and him
just you and him like he looked like for
real
for real texas good you looked good
um you were winking at him the whole
night you set it up for a couple of days
like when's the last time you went and
did that
um we'd went on one of those overnight
dates um
last year for his birthday
[Laughter]
so you threw in the overnight date well
played on that one and
the the birthday date right so so what i
want you to begin to think of
is a world where y'all can have a life
a romantic life a rebuilt life
a life that is a completely new picture
that is beyond
the birthday overnight date and the the
anniversary overnight right right the
overnight day the obligatory dates there
but the ones where
you can set out to date again and now
y'all been married for 25 years y'all
can even hook up on the first date
you can recreate what you want to do
where you want to be
here's the here's the big thing paint a
new picture together
and you said something earlier that i
wrote down and it's this idea of
this hope i hope that my husband has
received my
love language my love language of
service of
man every time you come home you've got
food here's the deal he has received
that
no question about it but i want you to
move past this word of hope
i want you to move past this word of i
hope so i think so
into i know so and the way you do that
is to have a direct there's probably
several direct
conversations several direct
we're going to take another out-of-town
date and we're going to revision life
what do we want to do in five years
because we don't have
any looney tune kids in the house
you mom you're gonna have to probably go
see a counselor
get a a couple of older women in your
life that you trust
because you're gonna have to unhinge
your identity from
um ever present super on top of
everything mom
to a woman who is madly wildly in love
with this knuckleheaded husband that i
married
a quarter of a century ago and you're
gonna have to re
create a new identity in yourself right
so i can do that
that's so i can hear it in your voice
and you're making me smile right now
because you're so rare you are rare rare
rare cindy
and god bless you so here's here's a
couple things
build something new together dream dream
together
start to date one another and not just
perfunctory like hey it's taco tuesday
at rosa's let's just go
i mean make it a thing once or twice a
week and i sound like i'm over
sexualizing this
i'm not but what i'm trying to do is to
let you guys know that you're gonna have
to be intentional about re-sparking this
thing
you're gonna have to be intentional
about recognizing oh we can just walk
around the house naked because there's
no kids here
and then you can be intentional about we
could just both decide to lose a bunch
of weight together we could both
decide to start i don't know turn our
living room into a gym we can
decide that we're going to paint the
house yellow you can do whatever you
want
right and that starts with being honest
about what you want
honest about what and who your husband
is honest about who you are
honest about your financial situation
your kids all that stuff
right and as you move forward together
and recreate this new adventure it
starts with a conversation
that says honey i love you i recognize
that i think i've put you second over
the years
i've loved you as hard as i can right i
provided for you
i made sure you were taken care of but
i'm ready to move
back into being your girlfriend i'm
ready to move into
creating relationship number three or
number four
where we can dream we're not got some
financial security we got three kids
that we sent to college so that they can
put us in a nice home someday
we can live recklessly in love with one
another
and then you just have to decide and go
build it and it's going to be a
beautiful transition
here's what i want you to do i want you
to call me cindy after you have this
conversation or two or three and i want
you to let me know what your
what your plan is maybe you're going to
get out of texas maybe you're going to
build a new house maybe all just gonna
start riding bikes together
maybe you're just gonna like have two
nut dates a week whatever the thing is i
want you to call me back and let me know
and i spent a little extra time on this
i love this call and i love you cindy i
think you're incredible
all right let's go to um let's go to
connor in philadelphia
connor what's up brother how are we
doing uh i'm doing all right uh thank
you so much for taking my call dr john
hey brother thanks for calling in how
can i help
so i have a hard subject in my family
but my wife and my mother-in-law
they have a really shaky relationship
they actually haven't talked in about
four years uh after our first daughter
was born we have two children
and her mother has been addicted to
prescription pain medications and abused
fentanyl and morphine for over 15 years
and
i just see my wife struggling every day
with her relationship
and not talking to her mother but we
don't know what to do
okay so mom's been
an addict for 15 years is is there any
movement there any desire to not do that
anymore or is it just is what it is what
it is
so you know about four years ago what
what prompted her to stop talking to her
is you know her and
i said you know we can't just ignore the
problem right and right
let's sit down and talk to her and we
sat down we talked to her mother
completely exploded yep you know
adamantly denies i'm not addicted i'm
prescribed this medication but she takes
more than she's prescribed she
she uses multiple pain patches at the
time she's
definitely abusing it and it's she's
lost everything physically
she's deteriorating financially
emotionally she'll
she'll pass out in the middle of
conversations that we're having she'll
pass out while our children are there
it's just it's a mess and you know she
exploded at us
kicked us out and you know pretty much
that was the end of the last time we
spoke to her and that was in 2016.
yeah so i'm going to give you some hard
truth brother you probably know what i'm
going to say but
i know it helps to hear it from an
outside source um you cannot have a
functioning relationship with an addict
yep you can't she needs connection she
needs
love she needs people to keep showing up
and showing up and showing up
that may not be you guys right now with
small kids
and that's especially painful for a guy
like you who desperately loves his wife
and whose wife desperately wants her
mama to be involved in the raising of
the two small kids
having a grandmother that's around right
this whole
norman rockwell fantasy picture is gone
because somebody's an addict
and i'm not in the business of blaming
addicts
i can't imagine the story that your
grandma's experienced
and the the numbing
and the ability to distance herself from
those
that pain that that fentanyl and some of
that nonsense can provide
but the reality is your job is taking
care of your kids and loving your wife
the best that you can
and you can't do that in relationship
with a functioning addict
yeah what hurts the most you know and
and i
we my wife thank god she you know she
she works in the medical field and she
she knows that stuff i think that
the challenge for us is you know i i see
her hurting
and i want to help my wife i know this i
can do for her but
is there anything i could do for my wife
to try to help her cope with it
yeah there's a there's a a couple of
things one is
you can know this intellectually as a
helping professional
right i know a lot of things but it
doesn't mean it doesn't
really hurt when my wife says something
right
or when i call home and my parents are
working on something right
it still hurts and that idea of
knowing intellectually in your frontal
lobe versus feeling
and your amygdala is not sending off
signals that you're disconnected you're
disconnected you're just connected
so a couple of things one is i'm going
to recommend that you
this is just this is just husband to
husband dad to dad
that you yourself set an example
not through advice not through hey you
know what you should be doing but that
you go see a counselor
and when your wife asks you what you're
doing why you're doing it
tell her i love
you and i love our kids and i'm really
haunted by this situation that
they're going to grow up without a
grandma and i want to know how to love
you better and i want to know how to
love these kids better
and that's going to be a
signal to her that you are deeply
tethered in and that you're invested
and at the end of the day all you can
control is you right that's it
and so you're going to get some tools
and some relationship
ideas and some new strategies on how to
love better
but you're also going to signal to your
wife that we've got to put the fantasy
to bed
it's over the second thing is is i want
you to be somebody who
offers strong boundaries meaning
you've got to sit down with your wife
and say all right let's
this is 15-year addiction this is a four
years we're not talking
at the end of the day there's not a lot
we can do here maybe there's brothers
and sisters who can help with
intervention
maybe there's your you know your
father-in-law is willing to help help
you know and go all in with the army
that's that's one option
but it sounds like you need to sit down
with your wife and you'll need to paint
a new picture of what thanksgiving is
going to look like without grandma
forever
you're going to need to paint a picture
of kids growing up not knowing who the
grandma was
or only seeing them every once in a
while because grandma
checked out right for whatever reason
knowing that when your wife is
frustrated or she breaks down in tears
that she doesn't need advice from you
she just needs a hug from you to say i
love you and this sucks
it's not supposed to be that way moms
are supposed to be connected with their
daughters moms are supposed to be
invested in their grandkids life
and y'all aren't going to get that and
it's less about trying to fix it your
your wife knows what's up she's smart
she's brilliant she married a wise guy
like you
man it just sucks it's just a matter of
being with her when i tell you
you got to put the fantasy down my guess
is after four years y'all have had this
conversation how is it going
so it's exactly what you said you know
there are times where
you know we've we've we've said it you
know we've said this isn't
this is not a safe place for our
children to be though
the way that she behaves and acts now
being addicted
is is not it's unsafe for our children
and we can't i can't bring a
one-year-old and a four-year-old around
there
okay and hey listen listen listen
listen that's a big deal that you just
said that good for you
there's too many people who are trying
to live out a fantasy leave out a
i wish it was i wish you would and they
are trying to cram
a triangle through a square hole
man they're trying to take a like a
round peg and just
mash it through a triangle hole brother
and you've done some hard things by
saying
my kids aren't safe i'm not doing it
good for you good for you
yeah and i appreciate that and you know
it's it's hard and what makes it even
more challenging i think is my
my wife has memories pre-addiction and
how great her mother was
yeah and my mother passed away from
cancer when i
before i even met my wife so you know
our children don't have a grandmother
my mother-in-law is divorced from from
my father-in-law
from this like you know so it
it's just it's almost like a death of a
family member hey listen listen listen
while they're still living it's exactly
like a death of a family member
and except it's worse because you're
right they're still alive
you can't properly grieve it and move on
and so what you and your wife
have got to do brother you have got to
grieve it maybe even have a small
ceremony
and i don't mean that tongue-in-cheek i
mean a true ceremony
that you and your wife go somewhere you
celebrate a memory she had of mom before
addiction
when mom was whole and mom was safe and
mom was warm
and you you mourn the passing of that
you grieve it
and you cry like you haven't cried i'd
recommend that your wife
write a couple of letters that she's
never going to give her her mom
but write her mom a letter of anger
here's what you're missing
here's the beautiful babies you're
missing here's the
here's the narratives you're missing and
i wanted to write a second letter which
is here's who i'm going to be
i'm going to be uh incredible mom i'm
never going to be an addict
i'm going to do these things i'm going
to go to counseling i'm going to
double down on my husband i'm going to
be
an extraordinary woman and let those
things rest
and then you'll grieve the loss of your
mom i mean of your mother-in-law
sucks brother it sucks here's the thing
there is no way to avoid the pain of
this
because it's a living breathing hurt
it just is again brother i want to
commend you for being a great husband
for being an invested husband for
trying to love your wife the best you
can grieve this thing
let go of the fantasy and then start
building a new world that may mean
finding some older ladies at church who
become surrogate grandmothers
i've i had two grandmothers living and
my son when he was
five and six made best friends it was
like reverse dennis the menace he made
best friends
with an elderly woman who lived next
door to us she'd give him fig newtons
and he would
cut her little weeds with some some
scissors that she gave him and they
would chit chat for hours it was just
really beautiful together and they're we
haven't lived in that
town for several years and we still
write letters we still get notes
um and it's just a matter of finding
somebody else to get invested in your
kid's life
there's women out there who would love
to do that they're surrogate granddads
who love to be invested
but it's a matter of finding that but
don't go run find those things until
you've grieved the loss
and i'll also put this out there for
folks who have addiction in their family
it's going to sound like i'm talking on
both sides of my mouth but don't give up
don't give up on people keep praying for
folks
you can send cards you can send letters
that say i love you
if you've got brothers and sisters who
want to reach out and do an intervention
you can do that
um but protect your hearts because the
reality is especially with
with fentanyl and galilee man
you know prescription drugs addictions
those things are demons that just drown
family members
drown family members and to doctors he
keep writing that
nonsense man stop stop
quit doing that man you're destroying
families
help people get well don't just dope
them up to the point that they become
non-functional unsafe grandparents stop
man all right i'm gonna take a deep
breath i'm gonna exhale and we're gonna
go to i'm gonna smile we're gonna get it
back here i'm gonna go to
elizabeth in reno nevada elizabeth good
morning how can i help
hi thanks so much for talking to me dr
john how are you
i am doing outstanding this morning it's
a blessing to get to just hang out with
everybody how about you
i'm doing well thank you good deal so
how can i help this morning
so um my grandparents have been going
through some really tough times
um and they're just such wonderful
generous people
and i'm just having a really hard time
knowing how to best
love and support them in such hard times
tell me about hard times what do hard
times mean
so um a little over a month ago my
grandfather was diagnosed with
esophageal cancer yuck i'm so sorry
and he's in his 70s so he's um
you know he's really healthy for his age
but
um you know it's just been really
difficult for him and then
a couple weeks ago um on their way to
another biopsy
they ended up having to go to the er
because he
um turns out he had an infection in his
hip that went septic
and he was in stage three sepsis and so
they
um he he was he was there for two
and a half weeks and you know they were
just cleaning it out and
and trying to get him healthy and you
know they called this last weekend and
said they didn't know if he would make
it and so we went up there to go
just be with my grandmother
fast forward to kind of what's going on
right now he actually made it through
the surgery really well
and he's at home recovering
until he has to do another surgery to
completely replace the hip
um and praise god they actually had
another biopsy
and um it's completely negative like the
cancer went away while he was there
wow very cool which is
which is really amazing but um now that
they're back home i'm just kind of
trying to figure out
um how to help them they they don't like
to ask or take help they're really
generous themselves but
um you know they don't want to feel like
a burden to others and
i know they've got a lot of medical
bills and they're not really set up
for their future and so i guess i just
was wondering
how i can best support them and then
also kind of how to start
talking with them about hard things like
you know do they have a will or like
what's like the next step i don't feel
like they like to talk about those
things but
you know i i just don't know like what
role i can play
um yeah so here's the deal yeah your
heart is
gold and i can hear it through the phone
and i just want to high five you
from nashville to nevada nope no not
even high five this is
a pre-covered era two-handed front hug
i just want to tell you i love you and
i'm i'm grateful for your heart here
grandparents are precious and they're
beautiful and especially ones that sound
like yours that are generous and giving
and present
and there's nothing more challenging
than watching loved ones
going through pain and hurting both
relationally your poor grandmother's
just watching the man she loves on a
table right and the actual physical
pain that your granddad's going through
and then with that
feeling of helplessness right we can't
do anything about it yeah
um so there's a few things here that are
swirling around in my head and i'll just
lay them out in kind of a rapid fire
sideways crooked order here okay
the first thing i want you to do do you
have brothers and sisters
yeah okay do they love your grandparents
the same way you do
yeah okay i want you to connect with
them
and whether it is through a zoom
conference
or an email chain or a text chain
my preference would be you all get
together and hang out but depending on
where everybody lives and all that and i
know everything's the travel's a mess
now but i want you all to have some fun
times remembering
the fun things about grandma and grandad
the crazy things the mean
things when they were super hardcore
disciplinarians back when you were
little and how now they just laugh or
whatever
weird little paccadillos your
grandparents have i want you to
spend some time remembering one of the
things that
stinks about when when our loved ones
hurt
is that that becomes our picture of them
and it overshadows
it over weighs like a like a heavy
anxiety blanket
it lays over the just treasure trove of
years and years of beautiful memories
time together laughter
silliness all that stuff right so i want
you to spend some time
proactively with your brothers and
brothers and sisters your siblings
remembering the awesome okay that's for
you that's for your heart
what's going what's going through your
heart and mind right now here's the deal
you've recognized that these
pillars in your family that have held
you all up for years
they're getting old and the one sad
crummy part of this whole existence that
we share is that we all pass away at the
end right
and hopefully they've got 20 more years
that are of awesome fun
silliness my dream is that to be a 90
year old grandparent hosing my grandkids
off in the yard sneaking behind a tree
and just blasting with a water hose that
just sounds like fun to me
um my hope is that you'll have that time
but you've got a crack in the armor now
and now you've got a dose of reality
that's just never fun to have to take
the second thing is we often think
people are more
frail emotionally than they really are
occasionally people refuse to talk about
death
occasionally they won't have hard
conversations but often they crave them
they just don't know how to start them
and so one of the greatest gifts you can
give to aging grandparents is presence
is if you can't be in in in contact with
them directly is handwritten letters
make it a practice
every week that you write them one funny
story you remember
one time they really surprised you with
their generosity
one like you know deep track a deep cut
from
one of the stories that your mom and dad
told about him about hey one time they
just showed up with the casserole and
some money and helped us out when we
were
newlyweds those kind of old stories
write them down
and send it to them there's something
about it for a grandparent is
understanding that they are leaving a
legacy they are leaving
changed hearts that they have a family
tree that's going to go on and on
and the more you can reinforce that
either through
you know presence or through something
tangible they can reread and reread and
reread
i remember a conversation i had with my
grandad before he passed
when i called him and just said hey
listen i want you to know you gave me
your last name i want you to do the best
i can to honor that you've been a good
man my granddad had a reputation for
being really really really nice he's
just the nicest guy
and i told him i'm going to honor that
and even last night my post on instagram
had something to do with kindness
that's just become part of my dna but i
made sure i let him know this is going
to be something that's going to carry on
when you're gone
and then the thing about the will
there's no way to have that
gently or compassionately or where it's
not weird it's one of those
conversations that you just put out
there
do you have parents are they involved in
this or is there kind of skipped a
generation where you're connected with
your grandparents pretty closely
yeah my my mom and her sister are
involved
but um there's just some weird family
dynamics there too so i know there's
some
okay we'll save that for another call
um here's i'll just tell you uh a funny
story for my life and it's funny because
i come from a
weird family who's lived and worked
around death a lot
i had a close friend of mine um a really
lovely one of my best friends in the
world
and her dad died suddenly in a tragic
car wreck and he was a police officer
and i was on the phone with her and her
husband he's one of my oldest best
friends in the world
when they were looking for this magic
box
and most police officers have a box that
has all of their things in it their will
their passwords their bank accounts
because they know it any day
at any time i may not come home and
they're trained out of the academy
you leave your home in a state of uh
in a state of neutrality you let your
family
be able to grieve you and know where all
your stuff is and so police officers
live with this understanding i might die
today
and so i was on the phone with them when
they found the box
and it was a hard crying
hard it was a it was a deep deeply
tragic
but at the same time a beautiful moment
because i remember thinking on the phone
with my friends
what kind of awesome dad this is
incredible man he left it all
there just in case just in case and just
in case happened
so i called my dad who's a homicide was
a homicide detective for years he was a
swat guy
he still was working in a police
department um i called him and said
hey dad you need to get a box together
dude of all of this stuff i need to know
where your will is just in case
something happens
and i'll never forget elizabeth he
laughed and he was like
dude it's behind the thing behind the
thing in my closet
and i was like you got a box and he's
like yes john everybody should have a
box
and so it was this it was this moment
i'd built it up i was nervous like oh
let's talk about the wheels
and man it was just like i was asking
him hey can i borrow 50 cents for a coke
and it wasn't a weird thing at all for
him um he told me how the stuff's gonna
work who's gonna do how and what
and it just ended up being a relatively
high level
stress-free conversation and that was
all praise to my dad
for for doing that so i tell you that to
tell you i would enter that conversation
directionally
it's a math problem it's not an
emotional problem it's they need to have
a will
and you need to know how you can best
support their legacy their honor
um what they want to have done how you
and your brothers and sisters and
whatever messy dynamics how you can help
navigate that
and ask them directly they may tell you
we're not talking about a will
i don't we're not gonna we're not there
yet stop bringing that nonsense into our
hearts and heads
hopefully they don't they sound like
generous wonderful people and they just
won't but
thank you thank you thank you elizabeth
for that call thanks for reminding me of
how wonderful my granddad was
just spending some time in those
memories just sitting here on the radio
talking to you is a beautiful moment but
at the end of the day you've got to see
a crack in the armor
the strongest pillars of our families
are strong dads
our incredible strong moms
our grandparents who have always been
and it just feels like they're always
going to be
they pass away at the end and it's
heartbreaking
and i hate that it's got to be that way
but it is
there's just some stuff on this side of
the curtain we don't get to figure out
and understand why
but it happens and so the best we can do
is to honor their legacy let them know
that we are honoring them
live lives that honor them and then wow
be direct about the math problem where
the forms
where's the this who you want to have
the car how do you want us to divide
stuff up
those are the math problems of life that
people often run around and avoid and it
takes somebody like you elizabeth who
cares about her family just to kind of
head right into the middle of that
conversation and i hope that they
respond like my old man did
with directness with a smile with
laughter with
hey i'm a grown-up i've got this figured
out and i'll take care of y'all like i
always have
that's my prayer and hope for you guys
elizabeth and hey i got an email
um normally we wrap up the show here but
i got an email that i just
let's just we're here we're talking
about grandparents this is an email from
sharon
she here's her email my four grandkids
are all teenagers now this is the other
side of this call
my four grandkids are all teenagers now
it used to be
so easy to get silly and play with them
now they are older and i feel like i've
lost some of the connection
how can i relate to teens sharon
god bless you you're awesome what a
great question what a remarkable
wonderful great question
all right so here's the deal
grandparents
don't overthink this like i just said
earlier
i want to be a 90 year old grandparent
that when my grandkids are coming to
visit i'm hiding in the bushes
with my 90 year old wife and we are
crooked and wrinkly old messes
and i'm sagging all over the place
barely able i'm probably going to be
wearing grown-up spanx right but we're
going to be hiding the bushes
and we're going to have those super
soakers and when our grandkids get out
of the car we're going to blast them
i want to be those grandparents so you
ask how to be silly and play with them
here's how
be silly and play with them be silly and
play with them
get some kid at your church to teach you
how to tick-tock if that's even still
legal anymore
get some kid at your at your church to
teach you how to
send instagram message write
hand-written notes
about crushes you used to have before
you married that old granddad of theirs
right
ask him who they're dating ask him if
they're kissing boys
oh and give him a hard time about it and
say sil
go over the line just a little bit
sharon like are you kissing kissing
are you using tongue yeah and you will
freak out your grandkids
but they will tell that story for a
hundred hundred years
here's one story from my grandmother
that was epic my grandmother was
every tuesday the big shell came over
her head she got her hair done
every day no matter what the economy was
doing no matter what kind of work was
going
that hair was getting done and i'm
telling you i don't know what they've
made these space age
nfl football helmets but my grandmother
could have lined up against any
professional nfl center and dropped him
one because she was hardcore and she
grew up on a farm she was a gangster
ninja but number two
because her shell hair was just this
perfect
this perfect brick of aqua net and death
and listen
she was a proper always done up always
perfect
woman she's just incredible so the first
time my wife got to meet her
we met them at some fancy seafood
restaurant in houston
and my grandmother perfectly proper sits
down and as we sat down
they bring a trough of french fries to
the table next to us
and there were some people at that table
i mean probably could have used some
orange theory fitness in their life
at some point right that may have wanted
to check in with um
jenny craig once or twice right i mean
i'm just saying so
i don't think anything of it they bring
this giant trough it's a platter of
french fries and they set it down and my
grandmother
about this loud leans over the table and
goes
to my wife who's just meeting her for
the first time well the last thing that
table needs is another plate of fries
right
and we started dying laughing and to
think this proper woman had a good
old-fashioned delony
jab stuck up and i was like that's where
i get my sarcasm
and my goofiness and that's that opened
the gate to where we
laughed more in her last 15 years we
laughed and laughed and caught up and
made fun of people and made fun of each
other
and it just turned into this beautiful
thing so sharon how do you get silly and
play with them you get silly and play
with them
you show up you be goofy you be silly
you let them know that you're
a person you let them know that you see
them as people
and y'all are getting all getting old
together and it's a ah it's a beautiful
lovely
transition man today's calls make my
heart feel good i hope as you're
listening to this you're smiling
thinking about your grandparents
thinking about the grandparents that you
wish you had thinking about
new grandparents you can bring into your
life whether they're surrogate parents
whoever
i hope you're thinking about a beautiful
tomorrow so as we wrap up the show
here's theo man this is the greatest
song ever written of all time
by one of the greatest songwriters in
the history of the world and when i say
one of the greatest i mean
she came down from the heavens actually
um on day eight after he rested god
stood up and stretched and he went uh
i'm gonna make natalie merchant and he
dropped her down in the u.s
in the late 80s early 90s natalie
merchant was the lead singer of a
wonderful band called 10
000 maniacs and in 1992
the album our time in eden produced this
song
the greatest song ever written it's
called these are the days
and it goes like this these are the days
you'll remember
never before and never since i promise
will the whole world be warm as this as
you feel it you'll know it's true that
you are blessed and lucky
it's true that you are touched by
something that will grow and bloom in
you
these are the days that will remember
the days that might fill you with
laughter until you break
you might feel a shaft of light make its
way across your face
and when you do you'll know how it was
meant to be
hear the signs and know they're speaking
to you
these are the days and this is the dr
john deloney's show
you